it's great to welcome back to the show
today cal newport who's a computer
science professor
at georgetown university author of
several books and most recently which i
just finished
a world without email reimagining work
in an age of communication overload
cal it's always great to have you on
yeah i'm happy to be back
so um in the book uh a world without
email
one of the things you explain is that
many jobs even jobs
that don't really have to do with email
in terms of what the main
uh impetus of the job is
have become 20 30 40 sometimes even more
than half
managing an inbox responding to emails
in a way that is
anywhere from relatively to completely
unproductive you talk about the history
of this and it's really interesting
because
when email was introduced to office
culture you didn't just have
office culture and work culture as it
existed with the addition of email
it completely changed the way that work
worked
so to speak can you talk a little bit
about that first
this is what caught us off guard in the
world of work that when we brought email
into our offices
which we did predominantly in the first
half of the 1990s that's when it really
spread aggressively
through offices we did so for very
narrow pragmatic reasons
we were replacing fax machines we were
replacing voicemail
we were replacing memos it was like
great this tool is better at those
purposes
than the existing technology we were
using
once email actually got into offices
though it had an
unexpected side effect which is people
began using it as the primary means by
which they coordinated or collaborated
we introduced a workflow in which
everything began to be worked out with
back and forth
informal ad hoc messaging that didn't
scale
and soon we found ourselves overwhelmed
with all of the back and forth messages
required to support this workflow where
everything happens through back and
forth messagings and it's really that
workflow
not the tool itself not the way that it
replaced fax machines not the way it
replaced voicemail but this workflow
where we began to work everything out
with back and forth messages
that's what created the overload problem
that we're all suffering from today
to some degree it seems almost like
it's become background in this
particular sense my mom also
is a college professor and she's been
teaching for decades at this point and i
asked her in preparation for this
interview
you know back like in the in the 90s
before you were so dependent on email
for communication with your department
and communication with students and so
on
uh what consumed your day because
roughly you're working the same amount
of time but now a ton of the time is
email clearly
the email time now was for something
else before
she had no idea like in other words it's
sort of crept in in such a way
where she agrees i work roughly the same
amount i didn't used to do the email
thing
now i do i don't remember what i did
before is is that
surprising to you or does that make
sense
well i think we should not underestimate
the degree to which
this workflow in which now we have to
attend these inboxes all day
is really actually putting its hand down
firmly on economic growth
and looking at a college professor is a
it's a good uh
bottle case study because it's a it's a
job that has been basically the same for
200 years and in my book i talked about
my grandfather was was a great example
a very successful professor endowed
chair at rice university that went on to
be the provost of a theological seminary
incredibly productive such an effective
teacher that even to this day i still
hear from his former students he he had
such a big impact on his life he never
owned a computer until after he retired
i'm thinking his objectives were no
different than my objectives as a
professor today to do research in the
teach well
and he had no email and yet today we'll
spend like your your mom was talking
about
50 to 60 of our time on email it's a
real issue
so what is getting squeezed out here i
think productive output i think
the reason why non-industrial
productivity metrics have been stagnant
for decades even as we put all this
innovation into very rapid low friction
communication and computation technology
is because we are moving more and more
of our time into just tending this
communication and i think what we have
to do to compensate for that is we're
adding extra work
off the books we're working early in the
morning we're working in the evening
like we're basically trying to just keep
productivity stable
by adding a lot more hours into the mix
it's a huge issue and it's one i think
we're ignoring
one approach to the issue and some of
your past
writing has sort of dealt with this and
and there's many other people who write
about this
is about techniques and strategies um
train
others to expect that you check email
once a day or
at the beginning at the end or three
times a week or whatever and over time
that's going to help everybody or
write your emails in a way where you are
providing the other person
everything they need to complete the
task rather than
communicating the minimum which then
creates a back and forth over a week for
something that a five minute phone call
might be able to fix that's one approach
like the very nitty gritty logistical
approach
that doesn't seem to me like it really
gets at the bigger picture issue what do
you think that we need to be
tackling both the big picture and the
the nitty gritty
or could the nitty gritty really solve a
lot of the problem
the nitty-gritty alone is not going to
solve the problem and and this is why i
think we're stuck
is we've been trying to solve the issue
of email overload in the inbox itself
oh spend less time checking emails batch
your emails have better subject lines
write have better norms have better
expectations
but we can't solve this problem this is
one of my the sort of the big idea of
the new book is we can't solve this
problem just in the inbox the issue is
the underlying workflows
so long as implicitly the way that your
organization collaborates is through ad
hoc back and forth unscheduled messages
the demand to keep up with all these
back and forth threads
demands that you check your inbox all
the time because that is how your work
is actually happening this is why when
we don't change that underlying workflow
but just say have better habits
when you personally interact with your
inbox that fails
so my big push now is to get past this
this
moment we're in which we're extremely
subduing our productivity because of all
the constant context shifting and
communication
we have to fix the underlying workflows
that is the rules and the guidelines and
the agreements we have about how
collaboration happens
it can't just be rock and roll and email
rock and roll and slack rock and roll
and teams will just figure it out
that does not work it is a bad way to
build the metaphorical cars if you know
what i mean
and so we have to fix this at that level
before the messages get into the inbox
in the first place
in the book you talk about fixing it
within an organization
in terms of the communication with
co-workers and it's
sort of different at least than fixing
it when it comes to
people you interface outside of your
organization like for example
consultants working with clients which
you include examples of in the book
does it make sense to first fix it
internally
before doing it externally both of these
can happen in parallel
it doesn't quite matter that what really
matters is having that mindset shift
which is saying okay our work is made up
of processes we might not call it that
but that's what they are the things we
do on a regular basis that produce the
value for our team our organization our
company okay
how are we implementing these processes
how do we get the information where do
we store the information how do we
communicate with each other to actually
accomplish these processes what are our
rules for that
and if you don't have rules written down
the default answer is probably
this hyperactive hive mind approach of
we'll just work it out on the fly
once you have that mindset yeah you're
going to see those client communication
processes
let's make those betters they're
internal processes how do we schedule
meetings how do we agree on new copy for
ads
you fix those processes but the big step
here is that mindset shift
that even in knowledge work there's
things you do again and again
and either you have rules about how you
want to collaborate to accomplish those
things or you don't and if you don't
you're probably leaving a huge amount of
productivity on the table
one of the things you talk about in the
book is that when people
in the knowledge work space are
presented with this idea
in almost invariably they react by
saying okay yeah that might work in
industries a b c
and d but i'm in a more unique position
in my particular job in my particular
field with my particular company
this really wouldn't work uh and and
that belief
seems to be a very prevalent can you
talk
a little bit more specifically about the
types of changes
that probably would work in just about
any knowledge work field
well i think one of the problems here is
that when people think about
reforming email they think about okay
what if nothing changed about the
underlying workflow when they're
imagining it they're imagining their
work
as it happens right now under
organization where most things are
figured out with back and forth
messaging right and then they say in
that context
if i stopped using email as much bad
things would happen and they're right if
your organization or team uses this
hyperactive hivemind workflow
it would be a problem if you stopped
using it so getting people to look below
the inbox
and say no no we want to fix how you
collaborate in the first place so those
messages
don't show up in your inbox that you're
not figuring things out with unscheduled
messages
and we get down to the roots of it so
what do those changes look like
it depends on the process right so this
is why this is not a it's not a tool
discussion
uh it's a a non-sequatorious question to
say well if not emailed in what tool
completely it's not the question the
question is okay if not this hyperactive
hive mind workflow how else should we
collaborate or
communicate it depends on what you're
doing so sometimes these solutions are
simple plug-in technology fixes if you
have to schedule a bunch of meetings
you should absolutely be using a meeting
scheduling tool
having to go back and forth emails to
find a time to meet is surprisingly
cognitively taxing fine sometimes what
you're talking about is a process that's
very
rigorously defined it's the same steps
one after another this is what we do to
produce our podcast episode every week
it's seven steps one follows the others
those can often be automated in such a
way that no one has to send unscheduled
messages back and forth to stuff moves
from
place the place people see it without
having to do unscheduled messaging
and sometimes these fixes are about
making information and collaboration
more structured so all the information
for this project
is on a shared task board that we can
all look at we have highly structured
status meetings that are 15 minutes long
where it's what were you working on last
time how did it go
what are you working on today what do
you need to get that done great we'll
talk again tomorrow
so very structured check-ins very
structured ways of storing the
information that's sort of the third
category of what these process overhauls
look like so
the particular tools or rules or guides
depends on
what's the specific process that you're
overhauling but the thing that unifies
this all
is looking at all the processes in your
work life and saying how do we reduce
all of this back and forth unscheduling
messaging for each of them
you know one of the things i was
thinking of as i read the book
was that um there's a sort of maybe
parallel issue or question here which is
one that's been written about a lot in
the last five to seven years of
attention span
and there are very differing views on
this issue
i think i've read a lot of uh near
ayal's work where he says
he doesn't think that fundamentally
there is an attention span
issue but that the issues are something
different and there's others who say no
you know the the mobile phones and the
email and all of these things
have conditioned people in some way to
uh for it to be more and more difficult
to spend longer periods of time
focused on one thing is there some way
in which
this entire email thing of 30 40 50
of your day is dipping in and out of
answering emails quickly
to get breaks from the more serious work
may be connected less to systems
but to this attention span issue yeah
it's an important question because i see
a clear separation
between what's happening let's say with
our phones the attention span issue with
social media online news wanting to
continually go back to my phone and be
distracted
yeah where you have tools that are
engineered to try to distract you i see
that as very separate from what's
happening with us having to check email
all the time
okay now it has been common to look at
email through the lens
of a sort of personal addiction for
example when the hyperactive hivemind
workflow first took off in the 2000s we
introduced terminology like crackberries
to
refer to people checking their
blackberries all the time but i'm
convinced
based on my research that the reason
we're checking email all the time
it's not a failure a personal will it is
not an escape from
work that is uh difficult it is because
the underlying workflow what i call the
hyperactive hive mind
demands it if most of the way that
things get worked out or collaboration
occurs in your organizations with
unscheduled back and forth messages
there is no other way to successfully
interface with your organization than to
constantly be checking those inboxes
because that's what you need to do to
keep knocking these metaphorical tennis
balls back across the net to keep these
ongoing asynchronous ad hoc
conversations going
so when it comes to email i don't think
the issue is that people have bad habits
i think the issue is that organizations
are running in nonsensical ways
um last last thing i want to touch on uh
you talk in the book about
how many of the tasks that are now
distributed throughout the day
for a knowledge worker or professional
of different kinds
at some previous point might have been
handled by either an assistant
secretary or a position that now is
essentially no longer needed
to me that seems like a huge
cost reduction for many companies
is that an economic reality that will
resist
the types of changes you're talking
about because it is so much
less expensive or is the counter that
the lost productivity because a lot of
these professionals are doing these
things
throughout the day essentially outweighs
the cost savings of
not having the assistant or the
secretary i think the latter is true
i mean there are some studies that
actually quantify this one of the
studies i talk about in the book
was watching the arrival of personal
computers and the collection of fortune
500 companies and
what they saw and what they observed in
this research is that yes they fired a
lot of the support staff because
technically
the computer made it easy enough to do a
lot of the things that the support staff
was doing that the
front line executives could do it
themselves but this researcher
he actually tracked the numbers and
found out that they ended up having to
hire more
of the much higher paid executives to
get the same amount of work done because
so much of their day now was spent doing
things like word processors and
communication etc
that the salary cost went up so they
save salary costs by firing support
staff
but then increase salary costs by having
to hire more people to get the same
amount of work done and they ended up
worse off because these salaries were
higher
i think we missed the mark on the
digital productivity revolution as
technology made certain
administrative tasks easier the right
move was not to
move all of that work onto the plate of
the the executives or frontline value
producers it should have been to make it
cheaper to have support staff i think
the right application of that of that
technology would be oh fewer support
staff can now support
more of the frontline workers that was
probably the right way to
to approach the productivity revolution
in terms of maximizing return instead we
said
let's fire the support workers and make
everyone a part-time administrative
assistant and a part-time whatever their
main job is
we know the way the brain works that
that is a that was a bad mix so i think
we really missed the mark on this
digital productivity
revolution it does make us much more
productive
if we use that to actually empower
support staff to be even more effective
not to put more things on the plate of
the people that you wanted thinking
about the ad copy or making the
executive decisions or writing the
academic papers or whatever it is you
had hired them to do
right uh that it's it's a fascinating
book
the book is a world without email
reimagining work in an age of
communication overload you know i find
that so often
when i talk to people about this book
other books you've written and and other
there's this visceral reaction like that
would never work we shouldn't even be
thinking about that do you do you see
is that is that a common reaction from a
lot of people well i think the key thing
with this book is
understanding that you're changing the
workflow because as soon as you say just
you need to spend less time on email
they're so overwhelmed by this
hyperactive hive mind workflow like are
you kidding me
i i would be dead because everything is
happening in the inbox but the real aha
moment for most people is when you say
yeah the reason why that's happening is
because the underlying agreements by how
work happens is generating all these
messages
and it doesn't have to be that way and
you tell them about companies where they
don't use email
and they don't use slack and they don't
have an inbox to check and they do one
thing at a time and maybe they work on
three things each day and when you show
them those stories
you can just see the light turn on
behind their eyes so
i think that's key the way we work today
makes it impossible not to check email i
agree
we can fix the underlying way we work
though we've been speaking with cal
newport computer science professor at
georgetown university will link to the
latest book a world without email
cal always great having you on thanks
david